Hello everyone, this is
Dr. Carl Abraham giving
this lecture on HIV, AIDS,
and human retroviruses.
I hope everyone is well
and having a great day.
If you're all ready to
learn, let's get started.
So our goal for today is
to explain where HIV came
from, describe the
classification, structure,
and life cycle of HIV,
and the mechanism by which
HIV is transmitted and its
pathogenesis. We're going
to talk about what
happens to a person who's
infected with HIV over time
and then talk about some
of the treatments and
the mechanisms of action.
Throughout this lecture,
we'll talk about a patient
and how to manage them
throughout this process.
Below is the
recommended reading.
There's a short section on
HTLV, and we are not going
to spend a lot of time on
that during this lecture.
I've given you two
options for HIV.
They are both good summaries.
I like the first one
just a bit better.
Let's talk about HTLV first.
This is endemic to
Japan, the Caribbean,
South America, and
Africa, and normally
only occurs in long
-time residents.
There are four virus types.
Only HDLV1 and HDLV2 have been
known to cause human disease.
Approximately 5 to
20 million people
globally are infected
with these viruses.
HDLV1 causes tropical *******
periparesis, a myelopathy
that results in neurologic
abnormalities such as
weakness, rigidity, spasm,
and sensory disturbances,
usually occurring in the
legs and is mild at first but
progresses to the rest of
the body and becomes severe.
However, PSP occurs in the vast
minority of those
who are infected.
The significant impact
of HTLV-1 is leukemia
and lymphoma, which
occurs in approximately
half a million infected
persons every year.
There is no antiretroviral
treatment to
prevent the development
of leukemia or lymphoma,
and once it occurs,
they respond poorly
to chemotherapy, and
the prognosis is poor.
HTLV2 is less clinically
significant and causes
neurologic abnormalities
and chronic pulmonary
disease, but most
persons who are infected
remain asymptomatic
throughout their life.
There are recently two
other HTLV viruses,
three and four, that
have been identified in
only a few persons in
Africa, but no disease
has been associated
with these viruses yet.
More information about HDLV can
be found in the
assigned reading.
Let's now talk
about HIV, and we'll
do so by way of
an introduction.
Meet Bobby, a 25-year
-old male who comes
for STI testing after
unprotected ***.
You do a complete history
and physical, including
an anogenital exam,
and it's unremarkable.
You recommend tests for
HIV, ********, gonorrhea,
chlamydia, hepatitis
B, and trichomonas.
And despite several
unprotected exposures and the U
.S. Preventive Services Task
Force recommendation that
all between the ages of
15 and 65 have at least
one HIV test, he has not had
one and refuses HIV testing
now because he thinks
HIV is a government plot.
Where do you tell
Bobby HIV came from?
Bobby's belief of a
government plot is incorrect.
However, I challenge you
not to discount these
beliefs outright, but
to understand why they
exist. And I'm not saying
this belief exists because
it contains a sliver
of truth, but it does.
During the European
colonization of
Africa during the 18th
and 19th centuries,
Progressive encroachment
on untouched forest
and deforestation
increased contact between
humans and animals.
This resulted in
increased exposure of
humans to animal viruses,
and the virus in
question here is
simian immunodeficiency
virus, or SIV.
As the population of these
occupiers and the demand
grew, more and more wild animals
were brought into village
centers to be sold in
markets for food. This is
called bushmeat. This practice
continues today, but at
some point, simian
immunodeficiency virus infecting
chimpanzees and other primates
was transmitted to humans.
Based on analyses of viral
genomes and estimates
based on rates of
mutation, this jump to
human hosts most likely
took place between
1884 and 1924, probably
in the Belgian Congo.
Spread of the virus
occurred along trade
routes from the
Congo to Kinshasa,
the major population
center at the time.
The earliest case of confirmed
HIV was found in stored
tissue samples from a patient
dating back to 1959. By
that time, there was
considerable genetic diversity
in the HIV-1 virus, indicating
it had been circulating
in humans in the vicinity
of Kinshasa for some time.
Infrequent cases of AIDS
-like illnesses were described
throughout the 20th century
from the 1930s. These
are not proof that these
persons had HIV, but it is
possible given the
epidemiologic connections these
patients had with Africa and
those who traveled there.
The beginning of the
current pandemic was
ushered in 1981 and reported
as two almost simultaneous
case series in the
MMWR describing men
having *** with men in
New York and San Francisco
who developed two very
unusual conditions,
pneumocystis carinii
pneumonia, which is now called
pneumocystis urovicii,
and rapidly progressive
diffuse superficial and
visceral Kaposi sarcoma.
These were rare in persons
who were otherwise thought
to be healthy with no
known immune deficiency.
In fact, Kaposi's was a
slow-growing cancer that,
although had been described
rarely in the U.S., was
known primarily to occur
on the skin of the feet
in elderly Ashkenazi Jews
along the Mediterranean.
What's more, these case
reports described the presence
of multiple opportunistic
infections such as
disseminated cytomegalovirus,
invasive candidiasis,
necrotizing CNS toxoplasmosis,
cryptococcal
meningitis, and severe
recurrent ******
simplex infection that
suggested severe
immune suppression.
It took two years to
identify the cause of HIV,
and while a complete
history of the HIV
pandemic is beyond the
scope of this course, there
are important landmarks,
such as the incredible
number of deaths that
occurred from AIDS
prior to active antiretroviral
therapy in 1995,
the ability to drastically
decrease mother
-to-newborn transmission
beginning in 1994,
the millions of orphans
of sub-Saharan Africa, the
altogether loss of 40 million
lives by the end of 2020,
all incompletely tempered
by meeting the UNAIDS goals
set in 2014 of 90% of
people living with HIV know
their status, 90% of those
who know their status be
on antiretrovirals, and 90%
of those on antiretrovirals
being virally suppressed
by 2020. These goals
were met. The 95-95-95
targets set in 2020, have the
goal of ending the worldwide
HIV pandemic by 2030.
In 1995,
highly active
antiretroviral therapy was
introduced that in developed
countries drastically
decreased rates of
death in those with HIV.
Within just a few years,
HIV wards that were
once filled with patients
on their deathbed
were closed because the
health of persons living
with HIV and AIDS
dramatically improved, and
so few were being
admitted to the hospital.
And throughout the last
10 years, the number
of those treated
throughout the world has
also increased
dramatically, so that now 81
% of those living with
HIV are on treatment.
and now you know a lot
about hiv and you don't
tell all of that to bobby
but you tell him enough
that he reports that
he's having unprotected
*** with multiple men and
women has been treated
for gonorrhea ********
and has recurrent *******
****** and in the past
many years ago he shared
needles with others when
he was using ******.
What do you think is Bobby's
risk of having HIV infection?
So how is HIV transmitted?
HIV-contaminated blood
products have the highest rates
of transmission, with greater
than 90% of those exposed
to an infected unit of
blood acquiring infection.
Rates for other modes of
transmission are much lower.
For example, receptive
**** *********** is about 1
.4 percent, sharing contaminated
needles 0.6 percent,
percutaneous needle stick
injuries 0.2 percent, and
insertive **** ***********,
receptive vaginal and
insertive vaginal 1, 0.8,
and 0.4 percent respectively.
Transmission of HIV during
*********** increased up
to five times if *******
or **** ulcers are present.
Before widespread
testing of the blood
supply in 1985 made
transmission from
contaminated blood and
blood products rare,
more than 14,000 persons
were infected after blood
transfusion and 5,000
persons with hemophilia A
were infected, 4,000 of
whom eventually succumbed
to the disease. One of
the great victories during
the pandemic was prevention
of mother-to-child
transmission using
intrapartum and postpartum
antiretroviral therapy, both
in the U.S. and throughout
the world. And the
development of clean needle
programs in metropolitan
areas has decreased
transmission among injection
drug users substantially.
It is important to note
that HIV is not transmitted
through the air,
mosquitoes, touch, eating
utensils, body fluids,
or any other fluids not
discussed above, including
sweat, tears, and saliva.
However, these myths
are still widespread.
Bobby's risk depends on
his exposures, but it also
depends on who he is. In the
U.S. in 2018, there were 36
,400 persons newly infected
with HIV, and rates in men
were five times that in women.
Men who had *** with men
accounted for the greatest
number of new infections,
less so men who
have *** with women,
and even less so
injection drug users.
Most new infections in men
occurred in those who are
black, who despite being
13% of the population in
2018, made up 39% of new
infections in all men, and
37% of new infections in
men who have *** with men.
Latino men are also
overrepresented based on
population, making both black
and Latino men who have ***
with men vulnerable
populations in HIV infection.
The same racial
disproportions are seen
in transgender men
and women who make up
a significant number
of new infections.
In the U.S., women are
primarily infected by *** with
men. Again, there are a
disproportionate number
of black women infected,
and it is startling to see
the rates of infection in
women in the southern U.S.
Those living with
HIV in the U.S.
commonly live in the
poorest communities.
As we mentioned when we talked
about new infections in women,
most new infections in
the U.S. overall occur in
the south and in urban areas
throughout the country.
And I wanted to point out
that these demographics
are very different in other
parts of the world. Here
is data from Kenya, where
most transmission occurs
in heterosexual couples in
long-term relationships,
and heterosexual
*********** makes up nearly
80% of new infections, very
different than the U.S.
So you let Bobby know
that his behavior
puts him at very high risk of
getting HIV and
recommend HIV testing.
He admits he doesn't
understand what the virus
is and how it can infect
him or make him sick.
What can you tell Bobby
to make him more informed?
HIV is a retrovirus,
member of the lentivirus
family, that includes
HIV-1, HIV-2, and SIV.
There are many other
retroviruses that infect
animals, but only four
others infect humans,
the HTLV viruses that
we talked about earlier.
All retroviruses
contain a single
-stranded positive
cent RNA genome.
The figure on the left
shows the viral genome
up top and below, a
virion sliced in half.
The genome contains three
main reading frames,
GAG, POL, and ENV.
These code for capsid
and viral accessory
proteins, proteolytic
enzymes, and envelope
proteins, respectively.
The virus is surrounded
by a lipid bilayer, or
envelope, that originates
from infected cells.
Stock-like protein
GP41 spans the
lipid envelope
to support GP120,
the viral antigen that
binds the CD4 receptor on
the T helper cell to
begin the HIV life cycle.
We'll look at that in more
detail in a couple of slides.
Lining the inside and
helping to maintain
the integrity of the
envelope is matrix protein
P17, and all of this
surrounds the conical
viral capsid, which
is composed of P24.
The capsid houses
the RNA genome, which
is lined with
stabilizing proteins.
Prior to infecting
a cell, the reverse
transcriptase, integrase,
and protease enzymes
exist in inactive forms
within the capsid.
On the right is a
short video that
is more structurally accurate.
At the bottom of the
slide, there is a link to
the full video, which is
quite remarkable. It shows
the entire HIV life
cycle, and it was produced
by Dr. Janet Asawa. It
is really worth watching.
Of course, you'll have
to stop this video, go
to the PowerPoint
presentation in order to
click that link, but
that's okay. Go ahead,
pause the video, go to
the PowerPoint, click
the link, and I'll wait
until you... Welcome
back. Here's another
look at the major
proteins encoded
by the HIV genome.
We've talked about GAG,
POLL, and ENV. There are
also other genes that
are not within the main
reading frames, some of
them discontinuous, and
even one, NEF, within
a long-terminal repeat.
These proteins elegantly
give HIV an advantage
over the host cell by
decreasing host cell
defenses and preventing
the expression of CD4
receptors on the surface
by degrading them
intracellularly, and the
product of the NEF gene, the
one that's in the three
-prime long-term repeat,
down regulates both CD4 and
MHC1 expression, resulting
in an infected T helper
cell's inability to bind
both antigen-presenting
cells or to bind antigen
itself, preventing the T
cell's activation. Oh, and
for those of you who did
not look at that video on
the last slide, I've put
a link to it here, and
now that we've reviewed all
of these proteins again,
it will make even more
sense. So go ahead
and get that link and
check out that video.
Here's how HIV infects
cells. The virion binds to
the T helper cell via an
interaction between GP120
and the CD4 receptor on
the T helper cell surface.
This is shown on the top left.
Once bound, a co-receptor on
the T helper cell membrane,
CCR5, binds the GP120
-CD4 complex to cause a
conformational change in
GP120, allowing it to first
insert itself into the T
cell membrane and then fold
back on itself, approximating
the viral and cell
membranes resulting in membrane
fusion. The ***** capsid
enters the cytoplasm,
and while traveling along
microtubules, the reverse
transcriptase is activated,
transcribes first a negative
-sense DNA strand, denatures
the viral RNA, and then
reverse transcribes the DNA
strand to form a double
-stranded DNA viral genome.
Viral integrase attaches
to and facilitates the
migration of the viral
DNA through a nuclear pore
and integrates it into
the host genome. At that
point, the viral genome
is called a provirus as it
is integrated into the
host DNA and it can remain
latent for days, weeks,
years, and even longer.
At some point in the future,
cellular RNA polymerase
transcribes the integrated
viral genome to produce
viral RNA that migrates to
the cytoplasm and is either
translated on ribosomes to
produce the viral proteins
and enzymes or are
incorporated into assembling
viral capsids. Once assembled,
the capsid abuts the
inner surface of the cell
membrane and buds from the
cell to be surrounded by
the lipid bilayer envelope.
Throughout this slide,
you see in red the names
of antiretrovirals and at
which points they act in
the life cycle. You'll
learn a lot more about
these during your pharmacology
lecture on antiretroviral
therapy, and we'll
talk a little bit more
about antiretrovirals to
some extent down the line.
There is one I'd like
to point out on this
slide, and at the top
left, that is Moraviroc.
Moraviroc acts to prevent
CCR5 from binding with GP120
and the CD4 receptor. This
prevents HIV from being
able to enter the T helper
cell in the first place.
CCR5 is thought to be the
co-receptor on T helper
cells in just about every
newly infected person,
but in some people over
time, that co-receptor
may switch to another
molecule called CXCR4.
And in those persons, HIV
evolves to use CXCR4 as a co
-receptor. And in some people,
it becomes a mix of CCR5
and CXCR4, and those are
termed dual tropic viruses.
The point is, in those
persons who have either
a mix or solely CXCR4
as the co-receptor,
Meraviroc no longer works.
We'll talk even more
about CCR5 when we talk
about possible cures for HIV.
Here is a scheme of the
time course of someone
who is infected with HIV
who does not get treated.
This is something we
hope doesn't happen
today, but it was
typical of most
patients prior to
antiretroviral therapy.
The graph is divided into
three sections. As we
review these sections,
focus your attention on
the curves showing the CD8
or cytotoxic T cell and
CD4 or T helper cell counts,
the anti-HIV antibody,
and HIV viral load. The
HIV viral load is the
number of viral genomes
per mil or milliliter.
First, there is acute
infection followed
very shortly by acute
retroviral syndrome.
After acute infection,
progenitors of activated
T helper cells do a fairly
good job of replenishing the
T helper cell population,
allowing there to be some
humoral and cytotoxic T
cell control of HIV infection,
causing there to be a
prolonged period of asymptomatic
or latent infection.
There are, however, millions
of T helper cells that
are being destroyed by the
infection every day, and
at some threshold,
replenishing just can't keep
up. As you've learned in
other lectures, the T helper
cell is a critical participant
in both humoral and
cell-mediated immunity.
Thus, as the CD4 cell count
decreases below 200, both
humoral and cell-mediated
immunity rapidly begin
to fail, and by the time
CD4 cell counts are very
low, say the single digits,
death usually ensues from an
opportunistic infection
or malignancy.
Let's look at each
one of these sections
of the time course
individually.
Two to four weeks after
acute HIV infection, many
persons experience acute
retroviral syndrome.
This occurs because HIV
migrates through the blood
to regional nodes to
infect dendritic cells,
another cell type that
expresses the CD4 receptor.
Viral replication explodes and
billions of copies
are produced.
This results in a
very high viral RNA
and an acute drop
in CD4 cell count.
Some persons actually experience
mild immune deficiency
during acute retroviral
syndrome that manifests as
oropharyngeal or vaginal
candidiasis. There is also a
vigorous humoral response,
so patients may have fever,
fatigue, and often experience
a non-exudative pharyngitis,
lymphadenitis, rash,
headache, aseptic meningitis,
nausea, and diarrhea. The
illness lasts a couple
of weeks or so, although
there can be prolonged
fatigue. An important
point is that the astute
clinician who sees a person
with risk factors and what
appears to be a viral
illness will have a high
index of suspicion for
acute retroviral syndrome.
Making that diagnosis and
placing the patient on
antiretroviral therapy this
early in infection usually
results in excellent
outcomes for the patient.
The asymptomatic or latent
period of infection lasts
on average about 8 to
10 years. There is a lot
going on during this period.
First, in the United States,
about 1 in 7 persons who
are infected don't know
it. There is a lot of
transmission during the latent
period. As we said
before, progenitors try to
replete the CD4 cell count
as HIV is killing millions
of CD4 cells every day,
but the CD4 cell count
progressively declines and
the HIV viral load, the RNA,
continues to increase.
However, it is this prolonged
period of immune activation
that results in metabolic
abnormalities increasing
the risk of cardiovascular
and renal disease, the metabolic
syndrome, hyperlipidemia,
fat redistribution, and
metabolic acidosis. Toward
the end of the latent
phase, some patients will
experience some constitutional
symptoms such as fatigue,
weight loss, or even
occasional fever. And lastly,
throughout this time, the
progressive loss of CD4
cells and humoral immunity
results in progressively
increasing holes in the
immune system. We used to call
these immune lacunae. For
example, someone who has
previously vaccinated for
streptococcus pneumoniae may
completely lose that
immunity gained from the
vaccine. How many and which
immune lacunae occur in
different patients is
unpredictable, but the lacunae do
increase the risk of
infections for the patient. The
final phase of untreated
HIV infection is the
symptomatic phase. CD4
drops below 200 and finally
below 100 and into the
single digits. This results
in a severe immune
suppression that in a
stepwise manner increases
the risk of certain
opportunistic infections
and malignancies. There is
actually an increase in the
incidence of tuberculosis
and lymphoma below a
CD4 cell count of 350.
below 200, there is increased
risk for pneumocystis
urovicii, below 100, cerebral
toxoplasmosis, and below
50, CMV retinitis,
disseminated CMV, cryptococcal
meningitis, esophageal
candidiasis, and disseminated
Mycobacterium avium
intracellulari complex. AIDS is
defined as anyone who has a
CD4 count less than 200 or
a CD4 percentage of less
than 14, but also when anyone
of any cell count or CD4
cell count has an AIDS
-defining illness, including
CMV retinitis, pneumocystis,
and the other conditions
shown above, period. There
are also malignancies that
are AIDS-defining illnesses,
including CNS lymphoma,
Kaposi's sarcoma, and
cervical cancer. Advanced
HIV also increases the risk
of other malignancies, such
as Hodgkin's disease, oral
cavity or pharyngeal
carcinoma, ****, liver, and
lung cancer. A link to the
current list of AIDS-defining
illnesses is at the bottom
of this slide, period.
And with that information,
Bobby is understandably
concerned. He agrees to
HIV testing, which is
positive. You counsel him,
understand how upset he
must be, and how worried
he is. You let him know
that with the current
treatment, he can expect to
live a very long life
if he is compliant. You
recommend that he use 100
% barrier protection during
***, and you let him know
that you need to order
some more blood tests.
What tests would you order?
We ordered the state-of-the
-art HIV test, the fourth
-generation antigen antibody
assay that tests for p24
antigen and anti-HIV antibody.
You will remember that
p24 is the capsid protein
coded for by the GAG gene.
It is generally detectable
in blood somewhere between
two and three weeks after
infection. Previous diagnostic
testing relied solely on
anti-HIV antibodies that
weren't detectable for up
to 12 weeks after infection.
So the inclusion of p24
antigen testing, significantly
reduces the length of the
window period, the duration
between infection and
detection of infection with
a positive test. That window
period is about two weeks
now, but even if the
fourth generation test is
negative or indeterminate,
if there is a high index of
suspicion, it is recommended
to perform a nucleic acid
amplification test, such
as an HIV viral load by PCR
that detects viral RNA in
the blood as early as one
week after infection. The
reason we do not use the viral
nucleic acid amplification
test first is there is a
significant number of false
positives when it is used
in this manner. Since we
haven't really talked about
it yet, let's talk about
HIV-2. It is mainly present
in West Africa, but the
incidence is slowly increasing
in the U.S., Europe, and
India. HIV-1 makes up about
95% of infections of all
people living with HIV. The
two viruses are quite
genetically distinct with only
about 55% sequence homology.
HIV-2 is approximately
10 times less transmissible
by heterosexual *** and 20
to 30 times less transmissible
from mother to child
compared to HIV-1. The most
current diagnostic tests
detect both HIV-1 and HIV-2,
but older tests could not.
The biggest difference
between the two viruses and
an important feature of HIV
-2, it is much less responsive
to treatment with non
-nucleoside reverse transcriptase
inhibitors and the fusion
inhibitor infuvertibed,
though the latter is no
longer being manufactured.
What other labs should we
order? Every person newly
diagnosed with HIV gets a
CD4 count and viral load. The
latter is the nucleic acid
amplification test we just
talked about, and we also
talked about the significance
of those values during
the discussion of the HIV
time course. We also check
resistance tests to see
what antiretrovirals are
predicted to be active against
this HIV strain. Up to 10
% of newly infected persons
may harbor a strain that
is resistant to one or more
antiretrovirals. And the
goal is to never place a
patient on an antiretroviral
to which that HIV is resistant.
Currently, there are assays
that test for resistance
to nucleoside and non
-nucleoside reverse transcriptase
inhibitors, protease
inhibitors, and integrase
inhibitors, and a co
-receptor tropism test that
determines whether the predominant
strain circulating within
a patient is CCR5, CXCR4,
or dualtropic to determine
if Maraviroc would be
active. If you haven't done
so already, you would also
check for the presence of
other ******** transmitted
diseases and screen for
tuberculosis, hepatitis B,
and hepatitis C. It is very
important to identify the
latter two infections in
persons living with HIV
infection. Tuberculosis, hepatitis
B, and hepatitis C have
accelerated time courses to
disease in persons living
with HIV. In other words,
latent TB progresses to TB
disease, and hepatitis B
and C progress to cirrhosis
faster in persons living
with HIV than in those
without infection. Identifying
and treating those infections
is, therefore, very
important. Many practitioners
also obtain hepatitis A
antibodies and vaccinate for
hepatitis A if they are not
present. The same would be
true if the patient was not
immune or infected with
hepatitis B. And finally, when
the CD4 count is very low in
a newly diagnosed patient,
it is very important to
determine the risk for
occult CMV and toxoplasma
infection by screening with IgG
antibodies. If positive,
the appropriate prophylaxis
would be indicated and the
patient would be sent to
an ophthalmologist. So Bobby's
lab work shows that his
CD4 is 150 and the viral
load is 150,000. Resistance
testing is negative. In
other words, the HIV strain
is susceptible to all available
antiretroviral agents.
Hepatitis B surface antibody
is reactive, as would
be expected in somebody
who has been immunized to
hepatitis B or had previous
infection. And all other
testing was negative. So
should Bobby start treatment
now, and if so, why and
with what medications?
The easy answer here is
that the current guidelines
recommend that all persons
with HIV be treated
with the goal of
achieving an undetectable
viral load. We've spoken
about a good reason why
he should be treated as
early as possible, and
that is to decrease the
risk of immune lacunae.
An important reason for
Bobby is his viral load. It
is quite high, and studies
have shown that the viral
load of 150,000 is
associated with a very high
risk of disease progression
and five-year mortality.
We know that the five
-year mortality of those
with a viral load
greater than 72,000 is
about 60%, and Bobby's
is higher than that.
On the other hand, if he
can attain an undetectable
viral load with therapy,
he can be expected to
live a near normal lifespan.
So Bobby gets treated
right away. What are we
going to treat him with?
There are many different
classes of medications
and different medications
within each class of
antiretroviral. They all
have generic and brand
names as well as three
-letter abbreviations that
make trying to remember
them very difficult.
Add to that a dizzying
number of fixed
combination tablets,
the various side effect
profiles, and drug
-drug interactions.
You would likely have to be
working with HIV patients
every day in order to get
them all straight. The
most important principle
of treatment is combination
therapy to decrease
the risk of acquiring
resistance, which almost
always happens on monotherapy.
Because there are so many
different treatment options
and so many different
trials that show efficacy
and side effects, the U
.S. Department of Health
and Human Services puts
out a new guideline for
treatment and management
just about every other year.
Currently, the recommended
first line for most patients
is triple-based therapy
with an integrase inhibitor
and two nucleoside reverse
transcriptase inhibitors.
There are many combination
therapies with all three
medications in a single
pill, most taken once a day.
Several years ago, it was
also found that dual therapy
using an integrase inhibitor
and a non-nucleoside
reverse transcriptase
inhibitor was non-inferior in
patients who had been
treated and virologically
suppressed for at least six
months. Again, there is a
combination once-daily pill
for this. It is likely that
these recommendations will
change in the years to come
as new therapies emerge.
You have an entire lecture
on antiretrovirals, but
briefly, the mechanisms of
action of each class are
integrase inhibitors prevent
the viral genome integration
into the host genome. The
drug names of the members
of this class all end in
tegravir, and the TEG comes
from integrase inhibitor.
Nucleoside reverse transcriptase
inhibitors are false
nucleosides that result in
cessation of transcription
by viral polymerase by
chain termination. The drug
names of the members of
this class don't follow a
special rule, but the most
commonly used drug in this
class is tenofovir, and
others end in bean or dean.
The non-nucleoside reverse
transcriptase inhibitors
bind directly to viral polymerase
to prevent transcription,
and these drug names end
in reen, peen, or ENDS.
The protease inhibitors
inhibit viral
protease to prevent
viral maturation.
The names of the members
of this class end in navir.
Moraviroc is an entry
inhibitor, and it binds
to CCR5 to prevent
GP120 binding to the
CD4 receptor, as we've
mentioned previously.
There are a couple of
other entry inhibitors,
and those names do
not follow a pattern.
Bobby begins Bictegravir,
M-tricitabine,
and Tenofovir
olefenamide, an affixed
combination tablet that
he takes once daily.
You counsel him about why
it is so important he be 100
% compliant with his
antiretroviral therapy, which
is to decrease the risk of
resistance leading to failure
of therapy, and to always
have safe *** with a
******. Because the CD4
count is less than 200 for
pneumocystis prophylaxis,
you begin trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole
double strength three
times a week, every
Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
and he receives vaccination
for Streptococcus pneumoniae,
Neisseria meningitidis,
human papillomavirus, and
we make sure his tetanus
vaccination is up to date.
You explain to Bobby that
what will happen on therapy
is that his viral load
will go down dramatically and
his CD4 count will increase
and eventually his immune
system will normalize.
And our patient Bobby
returns one month later,
we find he's been doing
very well. He has had
no side effects and
has been compliant. He
joined an HIV support
group and one of the other
members suggested that
he set an alarm on his
phone as a reminder and
that has worked great.
His CD4 and viral load at
this visit is 220 and 1500.
And you explain that he
can expect to have an
undetectable viral load about
six to eight weeks after
starting the antiretroviral
therapy. And he says he
feels great, but he explains
that he hates taking
pills every day and asks
if he needs to do this for
the rest of his life. And
will there ever be a cure?
What do you tell him?
So unfortunately,
you're going to
have to tell our
patient Bobby that
there is not currently
a cure for HIV.
Because it inserts itself
at almost random locations,
there is currently no
way to accurately splice
out the proviral from the
host genome. But there
have been exciting developments.
In January of 2021,
a long-acting injectable
therapy with an integrase
inhibitor and a non-nucleoside
reverse transcriptase
inhibitor was approved to
maintain viral suppression.
It is given once a
month. Other therapies to
achieve chronic viral
suppression are in clinical
trials, including a process
where the patient's T
helper cells are harvested
and the infected cells culled.
The remaining uninfected
cells are genetically
engineered to remove the
CCR5 gene, and these cells
are then propagated at
scale and re-infused into
the patient. This reintroduces
a lesion of T helper
cells that cannot be infected
by HIV but can achieve
a potent and indefinite
anti-HIV immune response.
The goal would be control
of viral replication so
that antiretroviral therapy
is no longer needed.
Early studies have been
very promising. On the
other hand, most vaccine
trials have been disappointing,
and there have been
vaccine trials for both
prevention of infection
and control of
the virus for those
living with infection.
The most logical antibody
target is GP120, as
antibodies to this protein
would prevent binding
of GP120 to CD4 and
prevent infection. However,
due to the hypervariable
nature of the epitopes
that would produce
neutralizing antibodies,
it has been very difficult
to produce a vaccine
that would be effective
for all HIV strains.
So you tell Bobby that
there is no cure, but as
long as he is compliant
and HIV viral load remains
undetectable, in the future
there is the possibility
for once a month
cabotegravir and rilpirivine.
After his CD4 count is
above 200 and the viral
load is undetectable
for six months, he stops
trimethobrom,
sulfamethoxazole, pneumocystis
prophylaxis. One year
later, he is in a monogamous
discordant relationship
and asks how to prevent HIV
infection in his partner.
What do you tell him?
Anyone who is at risk for
HIV infection can be offered
pre-exposure prophylaxis
or PrEP. It consists of
taking a pill every day,
usually a fixed combination of
tenofovir and m-citritabine.
It substantially decreases
the risk of HIV infection
and those who have
unprotected *** or use injection
drugs should be on PrEP.
It is an important
intervention to end
the pandemic, so
education of the
providers who see
someone at risk is vital.
Now, I realize we just
went through quite a bit of
information, and I'm very
thankful we've been able
to go on this learning
adventure together. In summary,
HIV originated in Africa
after encroachment of
forest land exposed humans
to immunodeficiency virus.
HIV is transmitted by
blood, ******, or prenatal
exposure, and all of
that can be prevented.
The virus life cycle can
be interrupted at many
points by antiretroviral
therapy to achieve
an undetectable viral
load. But left untreated,
CD4 depletion results in
progressive and eventually
severe immune suppression,
resulting in increased
risk of infection and
malignancy. And the HIV
pandemic has resulted
in more than 40 million
deaths and remains active.
But there are many reasons
to be hopeful it will
end during our lifetime.
Thank you so much for
listening. please don't hesitate
to contact me if you have
any questions either during
my office hours or by email
and you can also use the
link above to make a zoom
meeting with me using
calendly during office hours
this week we will go over
review questions for this
lecture during the 1 to 2 p.m
slot we really value your
opinion so please do give us
feedback on our lectures
so we can make them better.
And wait, like every
adventure movie these
days, there is actually
a post-credit scene.
There is more to Bobby's story.
After five years of
infection, he is doing great.
CD4 is normal, and
his viral load has
remained undetectable
because he has not missed
a single dose of
antiretroviral therapy.
His partner has
remained uninfected.
Then Bobby misses his next
appointment. That's really
unusual. You do everything
you can to try and get
in touch with him, but
phones are disconnected and
the letter you sent was
returned with no forwarding
address. This is worrying
to you because you know
that studies have shown that
non-compliance with office
visits is inversely related
to viral suppression.
but sadly despite being
a model patient for five
years and someone you really
cared about he has lost
a follow-up until we all
meet again in my next
lecture on opportunistic
infections and believe me
bobby's really going to
need your help see you then